let's check in with Kevin by a crowd
going
oh hey guys it sounds like a party down
near the main stage and it's a party up
here at the staging area you can see
behind me let's pan over here there are
people lined up ready to march with the
world champion Las Vegas Aces we have
the unle band we have some performers
from the shows on the strip and then we
have the main event not too long ago
about two minutes ago the player bus
pulled up and you can see them stepping
off the bus now as they enter the world
championship buses and those buses on
the right those will be the ones that
they will be parading down the strip and
earlier not too long ago we caught up
with Ace's owner Mark Davis who is
thrilled to be here today
the idea is to just win but it's to win
on and off the field on and off the
court and these women showed what you
can do when you get together in a
I guess come bring bring your passion
together on and off the field they've
done so many things and that's why I was
really Pleasant privileged to become a
part of the WNBA and the things that
they're able to uh to do off the off the
field off the court
of the world championship bus there is
head coach Becky Hammond she's rallying
up the crowd no player has come off the
bus just yet but the minute that they
enter This Crowd we know that they are
going to be ecstatic and here they go I
tell you what it doesn't get much better
than this we are talking about a world
championship celebration here on the
strip